But I want to play this video as well.
What happened to the Jews celebrating
Hanukkah?
So here's the irony of what happened at
Bondi Beach yesterday in Australia when
two Muslim terrorists 15 innocent men
and women ages 10 to 87 years old with
42 hospitalized while a man named Ahmed
Almed who happens to be Muslim at 43
years old steps in we've all seen the
video takes away the weapon gets shot
twice is celebrated as a hero which he
ought to be
>> now I understand why he mentioned that
there was a Muslim who attacked one of
the shooters
So now, guess what the liberals and the
Muslims are going to do? They're going
to play off of that to say, show you,
see, Islam is a peaceful religion. And
these terrorists are hijacking Islam.
That's not Islam. That's not my Islam.
See, Satan is smart.
One of the men
or the man who stopped one of the
shooters was a Muslim.
So they'll say, you see, he's
representing Islam. He is exemplifying
the spirit of Muhammad because Muhammad
did not teach to go around terrorizing
people. That's the satanic deception.
Don't you believe it?
That's the satanic deception. What do I
mean? Satan is smart.
The liberals and the Muslims going to
use Ahmed
to try to steal fears
of the rise of militant
Islam, trying to convince you that Islam
does not teach to subjugate unbelievers
and to strike at the kufur because they
are a threat to Islam.
This is the trick of Satan.
Ahmed would be what I call a good Muslim
in spite of Islam. You can have moderate
Muslims, good Muslims because they don't
know Islam. Let me repeat, they do not
know Islam and glory to the triune God.
God, glory to the father, the Lord Jesus
almighty, the holy spirit. The majority
of Muslims don't know the real Muhammad
of their sources. That's why, and I'm
not saying this to be politically
correct, there are many Muslims who are
wonderful people in spite of their
religion because they don't know the
religion. And in fact, when you quote
their sources to them and show them that
Muhammad was a terrorist, they don't
believe it. They reject it. They deny
it. and they call you right anti- Muslim
or Islamophobic because they're shocked
to hear
what their sources say about their
religion. This is a fact. We have people
in our channel who are related to
Muslims. You ask them, some of them
married to Muslims. Is your wife, your
husband a terrorist? Absolutely not. Do
they know a cintella of Islam?
Absolutely not. When you tell them this
is what Muhammad taught.
What is their reaction? Shock,
horror, and rejection and disbelief.
Ask them. They have Muslim relatives.
The last thing they're thinking about is
blowing themselves up and murdering
people.
The problem is there are Muslims who
know their religion, who know their
tradition, who know what Muhammad
teaches, and they're zealous to imitate
Muhammad, they're the ones who are
cancer and danger to the world. And if
it's only 10% of them, we're in trouble.
If you have 10% of 7 million Muslims who
are fanatical Muslims following the true
spirit of Muhammad, who is a
What's 10% of 7 million?
Give me this. The number.
What's 10% of 7 million, folks?
I'm not good at math.
Exactly.
You know what that means? America, if we
have 7 million Muslims, that means we
have
700,000 potential terrorists
living in our midst.
If the statistics are right, we have
anywhere from 6 to 7 million Muslims.
America, that's 700,000
potential terrorists ready to go down,
behead them, and blow themselves up.
So even though 10% seems like a small
figure,
small figure, it is not.
10% of 7 million is 700,000. Buddy,
you're worse than math than me.
You get it?
So how many Muslims you have in
Australia?
And there have been exposees
where Muslim clerics have two or three
wives. One on the record, the other two
discreetly.
And those other wives are booking the
Australian government for welfare
benefits,
right? Because they go there and pretend
they're not married,
right? and that they're single mothers
raising children and they're booking the
government to pay their rent or their
mortgage and their food and utilities.
You guys know this, right? This is a
phenomenon in Australia. It's a
phenomenon here in America. They're
doing it in America. You have it in
Michigan.
You have it in Michigan. You know that,
right?
You know that, right?
They'll have two, three, even four
wives. Only one is listed as their wife
officially.
The others are not listed because you
can't have more than one wife. So those
other wives go around pretending to be
single mothers.
Single mothers,
right? Raising children to then buil the
government of benefits. So the
governments now pay for their housing,
their food, their utilities,
and you're paying for it. You're footing
the bill.
It's not just in Australia. It's in
America. Can I give you a story?
Story. David Wood and I David Wood was
there. I was there. We are witnesses to
them when we used to do Jesus or
Muhammad. Jesus or Muhammad. ABN. We
used to go to Michigan.
We were contacted by Christian parents.
Their daughter had converted to Islam.
Now guess what? Their daughter was
working for a Muslim who owned a shop
selling electronics.
The man was married to a Muslim woman.
He sweet talked this young girl,
ended up getting her pregnant.
She had a daughter with him and then
married her in the mosque making her a
second wife but not on paper. We met the
man, we met the daughter, right? Because
we were trying to bring her back to
Christ
and exposing and refuting his lies. It
was David with an eye. Now fast forward,
she ended up leaving him. She ended up
returning to Christ. She's repented.
She's given her life back to Jesus
Christ and she found a Christian man and
married him. But it still came at a
cost.
He took advantage of this young young
girl
when she was emotionally vulnerable
because of a breakup. He did his thing
like men do, dogs do who don't fear the
Lord, you know, swept her off her feet,
knocked her up, then went to the mosque
and married her. So on record, he has
only one wife, but in reality, he had
two.
And now she has a daughter from him so
that whether she likes her or not, he'll
always be in her life. Even though she's
moved on, she's returned to Jesus Christ
and she married a Christian man.
This is what they're doing here in the
West.
That's what they're doing. They're
booking the government for benefits.
You're paying for it. You're footing the
bill because they have multiple wives,
but only one legally on record. The
others will then go and say, "We're
single mothers." to collect benefits to
have the government pay for their
housing, their utility and food,
while this man is visiting all of them,
knocking them up or having sex with all
of them. Because in Islam, if you have
more than one wife, you have to have
more than one place. Islam says each
woman has to have her own accommodation.
Each woman has to have her own home. So
if I have two wives, they can't live in
the same house. I have to get them two
separate homes or two separate
apartments.
You know that, right?
This is what you brought into the West.
Whether you like it or not, it's here.
You want me there? So,
the liberal media and the Muslims are
going to play the fact that a Muslim
named Ahmed stopped one of the shooters
to say see this is Islam. This is what
Islam teaches.
No, that's not what Islam teaches. The
man is ignorant of Islam. That's why
he's a good person. Let me put it this
way. A good Muslim is a Muslim who
doesn't know Islam,
who doesn't follow Islam, who doesn't
know Muhammad, that's a good Muslim.
That moment a Muslim learns about
Muhammad, knows about Muhammad, he
becomes demonized,
demonically oppressed, have not
possessed and evil and vile like
Muhammad.
So pray that all Muslims get saved and
those who don't never become good
Muslims.
>> But you know what the irony is? The
irony is even one good peaceful Muslim
man couldn't save the life of 15
innocent human beings celebrating
Hanukkah, which is what their religion
is about, from two Muslim jihadist
extremists, from killing them.
>> So, I don't care if 90% is peaceful. The
10% true believers jihadist.
>> I don't care 90% is peaceful. He's
right. Listen,
>> the 10% true believers jihadist.
>> Yep.
>> That hate what America stands for. Yep.
>> That hate the Western ideology, that
hate us protecting women, us allowing
women to vote, that hate the freedom of
speech model that we have, that hate the
second amendment model that we have,
that hate the capitalistic society that
we have, and we have to sit on the
sidelines and be worried about being
called Islamophobic. Really?
>> See,
>> I lived in Iran for 11 years and I saw
what this was all about.
>> He he he's an Assyrian Armenian who
lived in Iran. His dad is a Syrian. His
mother is Armenian, but I believe he's
born in Iran. He knows what true Islam
is. You can't deceive him.
[sighs]
>> If Americans cannot see what's going on
in Australia, tragic event breaks my
heart. There's a lot of Assyrians and
Armenians who live in Australia. And I'm
a Syrian and Armenian. There's a lot of
people. A pastor
>> see shamelessly wearing his cross. You
see, no shame, no fear in your face, a
multi-millionaire. And he's got the
cross of Jesus Christ. And he's gung-ho
for Christianity. And he's not ashamed
to mention he's Assyrian and Armenian.
Bishop Marmari got the eye. A Syrian
bishop who was very much needed. His
voice during CO got in the eye.
>> Exactly.
>> By a Muslim boy at 19 years old. Here's
a bishop that went to Gaza to pray for
Gazan families. He went there with his
church. A 19-year-old comes and the eye
and he still forgave them.
>> What are you going to do about this
problem?
>> Yep. Leanto and he's one of the few that
mentioned the persecution of Christians
in Nigeria
>> because our religion of Christianity
believes in that.
>> See,
>> we're supposed to sit in America think
[clears throat] it's okay with what's
going on in Dearbornne and Somalian
Governor Tim Waltz has the audacity to
get up and say we're going to let even
more Somalians in after a billion
billion and a half was stolen from
taxpayers over there. Really? We're
supposed to sit on the silence and be
vocal about this and not think it's a
big deal. We're supposed to do that. I
don't know about that. Listen, this is
what matters to me. I love this country.
I love America. And I fear the man
upstairs more than anything else I fear
in my life.
>> See?
>> More than anything else I fear in my
life.
>> You hear it? Bold in your face.
I love the man upstairs,
Jesus Christ. And that's why he's
flashing the cross in your face.
Liberals, in your face, Muslims, in your
face, Zionists, in your face.
Cross of Jesus. And I'm not ashamed. And
not only that, in his liveream, he has
an Assyrian flag. You've seen his live
streams, right? Or in his shows, I
should say. They're not. He's got an
Assyrian flag behind him, right
in your face.
There's the cross of my Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ shining.
In case you missed it, even wore a white
white shirt
in your face, baby.
Exactly. Um, fun. That's why you got to
be careful. We know. So, take it easy
and don't chime in too much. Let him
finish his his point and then we got a
few more clips and we're going to get
into
Jamea White and I'll try to do Doug
Bachelor. Let me know what time Avery
goes live.
>> The grace and the life he's blessed me
with makes no sense. Every day I'm
grateful for what happened. And I feel
bad because those 15 who are no longer
here with us, their kids will never hug
them again.
>> See,
>> there are no more dinners.
The family, the mom that, there are no
more, hey honey, no. No. Gone.
>> Gone. See?
>> Gone. Why?
Yeah. Islamophobia. Don't criticize
them. They're peaceful. Why don't we
pull up some data? Do we not see on SNAP
when all the SNAP government shutdown
was taking place? Who took advantage of
most of our SNAP programs? Who was it?
Which immigrants took advantage of what
SNAP programs? What did we learn during
>> Did you hear it? The SNAP program, the
Muslims built it like leeches. You hear
it? and you still sit there and you're
like, "Nah, it's just not a big deal."
Then you deserve everything you get
because we learned what happened to
Australia because the prime minister 90
days ago, stop being Islamophobic.
>> You know, he's Novak phobic. He's more
afraid of Novak not taking a vaccine
than these guys that are coming in right
now. Look what they're doing
>> to their beautiful country. And it's a
lot of Australians and Armenians, like I
said, that live in Australia. And you
see what's going on to UK. And then look
what's going on in Poland.
>> Look what's going on in Poland. Guys,
learn from Poland. Listen. Jesus
Almighty, protect Poland, a Catholic
nation. Lord Jesus Almighty, protect
Armenia, which is a Christian Orthodox
Christian nation. Lord Jesus, make
Russia Orthodox again in Jesus' name.
They're not ashamed of Jesus. And true
Orthodox that are not compromised and
ecumenical and will betray
their tradition.
But Poland, Catholic nation, right?
Look, listen to Poland.
>> They take nobody. Dominique Tarinsky,
>> he said it. The parliament, he said it.
Zero. Lowest unemployment, lowest crime,
lowest stabbing,
>> lowest stabbing, lowest crime, lowest
unemployment. Poland,
>> lowest any of that. And they have the
lowest population of taken refugees from
Muslim countries out of any country in
Europe. And they're crushing it. Maybe
what we need to lean on is God and data.
>> Amen. God first. Preach, brother.
Preach. CAN I GET AN AMEN? TONY.
>> God and data. Maybe we need to look at
God and data and make decisions based on
that. Anyways, God bless everybody. Man,
>> this guy's tempting me to go live in
Poland, man. Shoot.